hello in snow hey welcome to this video
playing me I
he doesn't oh my god
you get that so often kind of kind of
weird okay but he doesn't seem to so be
so well informed down the early c3 is
not not that great
you couldn't take a five because of
queen bee too
[Music]
I'm angling for quick be five before you
if he plays before now I would sacrifice
on before that is always possible like
it's always dangerous and in some cases
just winning for black so I'm willing to
take that gamble if you place before I'm
going to take on before let's see what
happens otherwise before would be a good
move like
need to waste time I'm going to do it
anyway
maybe he's a bit shocked yeah
doing it again so quickly but it's
nothing new I've had days on the board
in blitz games and now it's not easy
forward there are a couple of things
going on one thing that you should also
take note obviously I'm Kerri does that
is that Bishop III yeah it's also part
of this pollution okay now how do we do
it
Bishop c3 the checking of the rook I
guess
rook will probably go to a2
you
what just 94
there is 94
for sure well I can also think about b5
I wonder is Bishop c7 something that he
could do
94 they might be Roxy - Bishop c7 I have
b6 so okay I think I'm just going to
castle
now
night you for
let's do it
so we can castle now um we take once
stick once
now be 555
a5 Bishop c1 hmm that is not going to be
enough he had a bit of a problem
honestly and that doesn't it didn't go
too well that King didn't go too well
ninety-one maybe
I have a bit of compensation in in the
context of a blitz game but it's not
objectively good
not easy for white to play him bfj
coordinated somewhat discombobulated
position but
again objectively speaking it's good for
white I guess
I'm all set okay
moves the night away I'm not sure where
exactly
I would love to play the a pond like a 5
and before but I'm kind of stuck to the
bishop on c3
of course I can go before point to
before after which he will probably take
it and give the exchange but this is
something that I should probably be
happy to see I currently that wouldn't
even work because II too is hanging at
the end so I'm actually threatening
before here quite severely yeah this is
what he keeps that so let's let's play a
quick move and be a nuisance
exchange okay
yeah yeah I have to take it anyway
that's really no other way he might go
for some kind of attack like II for for
Bishop takes age six but b3 is such a
big threat yeah
so yeah let's do it these three
five would Atherton checkmate
okay
my frugal aides
Queen a1 is the problem a one
I can trade Queens it's a worm
you know there was a bit of an odd game
but yeah let's have a look there I mean
you went before and I think the sisters
work Oh Bishop cakes actually wins okay
okay
so I learn something new this is strong
okay well this is not the most subtle
Fred ever and it's very obviously strong
yeah why didn't I do that
okay it's very soothing don't move
no move if I let's say the line that the
engine is giving here and key this this
is just winning I mean something normal
like castles I'm material-wise I'm
already up and and this is the easiest
plane ever just bring the push this home
okay so I should have sacrificed the
other piece and this indeed it was not
really great yeah
so 94 seems to be better
ah okay I see him I know I see this this
is the idea that I have this move
yeah something like that that's a
bouquet one and that ticket this looks
good yeah very dangerous there are those
chicks and the King is is not to save
ever makes a lot of sense iam okay I
didn't see it
castled and now he was able to yeah sure
I completely missed the idea of of this
fork it was possible again he would tell
me he would need to take with the rupiah
and this is our this I'm very happy
about actually I think that the engines
evil oke form before as of is a is a
concrete idea but if I did not have
before it would be just lost
yeah simply be five and these pawns win
but he form makes it yeah indeed a
little bit makes it tricky I'm probably
go back take take and then he has come
to play here or maybe he's still with
this idiom okay Islands it I take with
this and Luke C aid and now yeah now
widest coordinating might be one was a
good move an idea three leads nowhere in
some some way I think I would have taken
it actually and then played b5 that's
what I would have done but the engine
just sing just gives white a complete
wind
five really
cannot see that Bishop is that the
problem that's upon the king
I simply cannot save it
oh and then I'm in big trouble
a arcane idea 3 b-52 should be 153
bishop C 2 we have K bishop C 2 s
assault but I thought you would go back
and then I would have also dropped back
and then see what he does plate this and
Dan now I'm just winning you know yeah I
cannot it's not really important he
gives a couple of double question back
most but it was just completely
completely over by that point so this is
a thing that I have to remember because
the position can easily happen again and
you have to take with the bishop yeah
never never I mean I never analyzed this
position so it's good to see that no
this is just a lot better tape with the
bishop okay guys thanks for watching